you know nothing Jon Snow you know  nothing Jon Snow you know nothing Jon  Snow you know nothing Jon Snow you know  nothing Jon Snow  you know nothing Jon Snow you know  nothing Jon Snow you know nothing Jon  Snow  you know nothing Jon Snow you know  nothing Jon Snow you know nothing Jon  Snow you know nothing Jon Snow  you know nothing Jon Snow you know  nothing Jon Snow you know nothing Jon  Snow  you know nothing Jon Snow you know  nothing Jon Snow you know nothing Jon  Snow you know nothing Jon Snow we tease  her about that like constantly she loves  it she's funny you know nothing Jon Snow  she does a little bit of that if not she  showed is that you're born in my back  Jon Snow oh it's a very camping show you  know nothing Jon Snow you little cheeky  monkey  you